abone ol
bu
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
sevgi gençler hepinize
Merhaba Hoş geldin o kadar çok Işıklı
ihtimalle dizlerinizi seçemiyorum o
korktuğu doldurduğunuz için teşekkür
ederim Bugünkü konuya sizin aranızdan
biri benim aynı zamanda öğrenci hocam
Gelir misiniz konuşur musunuz iyice
kıramadım Normalde bir tane seri
konuşmam vardı eleştiri üstüne Bugün de
hayatta kırılmalar konusu seçmişsiniz ya
da su yönlendirdi
aslında bir o kadar Sevindirici ve bir o
kadar üzücü bir konu
kırılma nedir En fazla artık onu bile
yapacak Allah
yolunda Şimdi Hayat Biz Ben el Bu arada
pili müzik ile Gazi Üniversitesinde
endüstri Mahallesi'nde Doktor an Var
sayılır artık yani bugün mezun oluyorum
Onun da şimdi araştırma görevlisi
akademik ters üretecek onun dışında beni
sihirli annemden oyunculuktan
sanıyorsunuz belki üç yabancı bir Türk
ler YouTube'dan tanıyorsunuz bunu
Şuradaki benim kendi kanalımı takip edip
size sadece vesaire ama bütün bu boş
şeyleri geçersek hayattaki kırılmalar
nedir
Bize öğret 2365 Eda ve Bugün Türkçe'de
şöyle bağlaç orada okulda böyle dümdüz
bir sistem ve hayatım hocalarınız olarak
ya da bizim öğretmen de hayatım böyle
dümdüz bir akışın Öğretim Şimdi siz
Anaokulu okuyacaksınız 8 sene lise
okuyacaksınız şu andaki bütün derdiniz
Büyük ihtimal sen mi şasesinde
rahatsızlığının ne kadar zor olduğu
matematiğin ne kadar zor oldu Sonra
bunları güzel güzel alınca
konuşacaksınız Evet evet 4 TL artı bütün
hazırlıklar yaptınız kesin bestele
bunları getireceksiniz Ondan sonra
Yolları bulacaksınız çok şanslı bir
kesersiniz İstanbul'da okuyan en azından
belli seviyede
ailelerimizin ekonomik durumla sizi
desteklediği destekledi beni dışarıda
öğrendiğime göre yüzde yirmi yüzde otuzu
muzun yurt dışında bir karaya
kovalayacağız tutuyorum Tıp okumaya
gideceğim Saki Mimarlık okumayı
Mühendislik okumaya gireceğiz
bazılarınızın 3 sınav gagasıyla size
kovalayacağız Boğazınızda burada güzel
üniversiteye gidecek önemli hayattaki
bir Kırılma Noktası Çok yakın bir
döneminde Evet şu anda size önemli gelen
ve gerçekten de öyle hayattaki kırılma
noktaları bizim için burada beni
dinleyen Büyük abim için değil hepimizin
yaşlı yaklaştıkça en yakın olan bize en
önemli gelen kırılma noktaları oldu ben
Instagram'dan bir soru açtım bu
konuşmayı biraz anlayabilmek için
sonrası hayattaki kırılmalar ne dediği
bir sürü şey okudu
Ben hep iki tane düşünce var İki sistem
var böyle işlemişler Yani o kadar İkisi
de mantıklı Ametist eksik birisi diyor
ki ben bir bireyi Üf Ben her şeyi
çalışacağım bunu yapacağım Bu olacak
Bunu yapacağım bunu olacak Bunu
yapacağım bozuk bir robot gibi insanı
her şeyi merkezine koyuyor ve hemen Bela
Rönesans diyoruz insanın merkezinde oldu
dönem için güzel Çünkü o zamanlar ne
yapıyorlar Ortaçağda Ben başka ne var
Ortaçağda kilise vardı
ama hayat hepinizin bugüne kadar
yaşadığı gibi bize bağlı değil Bize
bağlı ama değil ikinci görüş dava
kadercilik yani ne yaparsam yapayım ne
gelirse Gezer Ama zaten anne baba ne
yapacaklarını şekilde şey yapar akışına
bırakalım ona da Carpe Diem diler diye
Şimdi bu iki görüş kendi içinde
mantıksal bir tutun anayasada Hayat
dediğimiz şey benim tecrübelerime göre
kabul edersiniz etmezsiniz eleştiri
zaten bunların ikisini birleştiği yer
hayatta çok hafif bir ucuz
seçimlerimizde en baş seçimlerinde çok
basit görünce Çünkü ismimizi seçmedik
cinsiyetinizi seçmeli vesaire vesaire
şimdi Normal şartlar altında doğuşu muzu
kilomuzu boyumuzu vesaire seçemiyoruz
Yani biraz diye falan hemen göz
renginizi bile değiştiremediğimiz bir
sistemdir yani hayatı pasif durumda
geliyoruz aktif yaşıyoruz Ondan sonra
sağlığımızın zihninizi sosyal çevrenizin
olsun bize izin kardeş şekilde pasif
yaşıyoruz Dolayısıyla bu kırılmalara Ben
sorduğumda bu iki bazı anlattıktan sonra
hep böyle kötü şeyler geldi mesela Babam
t bu ne karıştı hayatımdaki en kötü
Kırılma Noktası oldu bir vefat haberi
var Belki biliyorsunuzdur 31 Mayısta Ben
de babamı kaybettim benim için Yani yeni
15 gün için benim hayatımdaki en büyük
kırılma anlarından biriydi hiç beklemedi
ama insanın ne kadar Pasif bir oldu
aslında olabileceğinizi anlatmak
istiyorum çünkü ki böyle bir şeyleri
koşarken esnek olmaya aklınızda
unutmayın Bunun dışında neden
bahsediyordum hep böyle
üzgün kırılma anları geldi şimdi hayatta
bu çok güzel bir şey ki hepimiz Bazı
yerlerde eşit Bu kırılma anları için
Hiçbirimiz muhabbet
bu topu kırılmalarına nasıl
değerlendireceksiniz bize ne
istediğimize taşıyor sıradaki adımıza
taşıyor Örneğin gidiyorsunuz bir yerde
çalışıyorsun Üniversite puanı
kazanıyorsunuz benim için bu Galatasaray
Ben sizin için Boğaziçi Belki sizin için
sorma bu bir kırılma anı ama sonrası
bulması değerlendireceğiz Buradan nasıl
ilerleyeceksiniz yüksek lisans ve
yapacağınız bakın yukarı yerde devam
edeceğiniz başka bir şirketlerini
gireceğiz bunlar tamamen sizin benim
hayat böyle dümdüz bitiren çizgisi artan
Hazırlandı Aslında farkettiğiniz fark
edemediğiniz hayatımıza gibi tüm kırılma
anları var bir de pozitif kırılmalar var
ya kalacağımız başında Şimdi benim
gençlere tavsiyem Eskiden çok kolay
düşün ki ve en azından Sizin zamanınızda
bizlerin zamanı başarı ölçütü bir doktor
olmak bir avukat olmak ne bileyim bizim
Yazar Olmak belki Gazeteci olmak
bunlardı Şimdi artık bizim sistemimizde
yaşamıyorsunuz Şimdi biz Çünkü neydi
bizim zamanımızda ellerimize de
telefonlar vardı bilgisayarlar vardır
Biz kendi küçük dünyamızda ben buna
örnek veriyorum ailemizin bize
gösterdiği Okulumuzun bize gösterdiği
kadar biliyorduk ve devamını göremiyoruz
Şimdi siz artık
önünüzde mezun olanların önünüzde
çeşitli kariyer Yolları yapmış olanı
tercihlerini ve hayatlarını
gözlemleyebileceğimiz bütün sosyal medya
araçları ve beceriye sahip Dolayısıyla
seçimleriniz de başarılı olmanın yegane
yolu başında profesyonel başarılı
meslekler olmadığını zaten farkımız bu
demek değildir camano zamanda gerek var
Dört sene okumaya 6'sını okumaya
bazıları da böyle sesler yükseldi bu
değil çünkü Ya ben her zaman
yönlendirmelerin de insanların genelde
bana sordu hep sosyal medyadan yürüyelim
YouTube'dan Instagram'dan yürüyelim
oradan nasıl para kazanıyor dendiğinde
bunların Çok riskli işler olduğunu
buradan kazanan tayfa'nın kazanan
kişilerin çok az sayıda oldu ve Elinizde
bir altın bilezik meslek olmalı çok ne
olduğunu dile getirdi burada Size gelen
tavsiyelerde bundan önce Burası Yollar
gelmiş şeyler gelmiş başarılı arkadaşlar
yapmıştım sucuk yaptığınız işin en
iyisini yapmalıyız birçok yere gitti
sizler gibi çok rahatsız liselerinden
öğrencilerin özel dersler verdi
anne doktor Baba Avukat
güzelçatı farklı bir ev
o çocuk PlayStation olmuş
ilgilenmiyor yani ismini vermeyeceğim şu
anda özel olduğu için ama ilgilenmiyor
yani bende yok diyorum yani şu bak bana
Hocam ne tavsiye edersiniz şu Çocuk
yayın oyuncu Bayağıdır yani Türkiye'deki
de falan oynuyor bu çocuğunuzun bu
konuda Kara dedi gerçekten bir mühendis
olarak şunu rahatlıkla söyleyebilirim
Bence arka planı tabi herkese hayatta
matematik bilmesi gerekiyor ama kimsenin
havuz doldurma problemi bilmesi gerekir
Bu gerçekten saçma Türkçede kimsenin bu
kadar uzun paragrafları yorumlaması
anlaması gerekmiyor Ama başarılı
olmadığı bir sırada Seni anlamak sistemi
değiştirmek istiyorsanız içinizdeki
anarşik ruhu idealist ruhunu
canlandırmak istiyorsanız ilk başta
sistemin içine girmelisiniz
sistemde başarılı olmanın Yok yok zaten
Kolay Evet şimdi diyeceksin ki abi
başarılı konuşuyor vesaire vesaire Ama
yok Ula
Ondan sonra bunun zorluğu neresindedir
saat iki saat çalışmaktadır ilk başta
buralarda başarılı olmanız gerekir Bu
başarıda benim mesela Üniversitesi'nden
iki tane saldır bakalım bundan çıktı
İkisi de tuttum Şu an
ben başka bir yazacaksın başka bir yere
gidecekti Ben hayattaki şans faktörünü
unutmayın Ondan sonra girdiğiniz
yerlerde aldığımız kararlarda istikrarlı
olmayı mıdır alkol sözü varmış hayat
bana doğru ve yanlış gösterdi ama ben
nedense Gittim gittim sürekli yanlışı
seçtim çünkü doğru çok soğuktu bütün bu
kırılmalarda yapmanız gereken
odaklanmamız gereken başarılar varca
Sizi rahatsız edecek şeylerden kaçınması
unutmayın bunları hırsız bir insanın
üstüne basma oy verme gibi kötü
edenlerdir bunlar bunları yaparak
başarılı olabilirsiniz dünya bugün
akademi'den sağlık şirketlerine her
yerde siyasetler içemiyorum bile ve
yayın basın organlarına kadar bütün
dünya böyle işte bunları yaparak mutlu
olamazsınız Bunlar sadece başarı getirir
bir para dediğimiz enstrüman herkes
biraz olan ve kimseye asla yetmeyen
müslümandır ama hayattan zevk alma
konusunda geçenlerde yine bir bir
Spotify yapıyorduk
dedi ki Türkiye'de zevk alma uzun yavaş
işlemi insanlar çok zengin olan kesin de
var ama sürekli biriktirme sürekli
biriktirme sürekli misafir yapayım
eğlenin yeni şeyler deneyimliyim Bütün
bunlar da buza Sizler gençler
sizlersiniz O benim de önümüzde
deneyeceğiz birçok şey var gerçekten
bunlara başvurmayı Özen gösterin Örneğin
Yani bugün üniversiteye girdiğinizde
kulüplere üye olur en büyük
pişmanlıklarından bir yeterince Kulübü
olmamış olmamış olmalıdır Örneğin
dağcılık riskli de gireceğiz
üniversitelerde böyle size altın
gelebilecek eskilerin tekmeyle ama çok
değişik deneyimler olabilir yani
hayatınızı belli bir alanda
akademik yılının yanında sportif yerleri
akademik yanında kültürel yerleri
geliştirmeyi unutmayın ya müzikten zevk
alın yöresinden zayıf ya da bir
profesyonel bir spor yapmaktan
zayıfladım günümüz dünyasında teki
zorları Bence bunu hep söylüyorum bence
Ben konuşuyorum yer yok Tamam hiçbir
peki drolet Yani yani alemin Şahı olsun
sadece aranızda uzmanlık Bursa Play
Station diğer yok bence Önümüzdeki
dünyada mm üçlü profesyonel arı
birleştirdiler ikili üçlü yetenekleri
birleştirilen insanların dünyası olur
sektöre girdiğimiz zaman göreceksiniz ki
ne kadar başarılı olursanız olun
pazarlama nız olmazsa hiçbir şey
eskiden de o bizim 50 60 lık kuşak böyle
her şey bu kediye her şeyde diye Aman
oğlum Sıkıntı çıkmasın Aman kızın bir
şey demesinler diye kuşak Şimdi artık
girişimci gençler alıyor Şimdi artık
birden işi yapacaklar Zaten yapacaklar
maaş alacaklar ama belli kritik eden
değiştiren sistemleri yeni şeyler
getiren yaratıcı kişilikler adı burada
biraz çıkıntı olmayı ihmal etmeyin bu
sıkıntılarınızı seviyesine ayarlaya
bildiğiniz ölçüde de başarılı
olacaksınız para kazanacaksınız istihdam
yapacaksınız ben kendi gelişiminize
atacaksınız ve şu anda devam ediyoruz
Hayat böyle dümdüz bir çizgi değildir Bu
kırılma anlarında borsadan örnek vereyim
Ben siz biliyorsunuzdur genelde dolardan
öğretmenim şu anda çok abartıyor sürekli
gibi gözükse de şimdi Normalde
Şimdi farklı zaman insanlar genelde
sahip olur ve almaya başladı ama doğru
yatırımcılar onu bir tat noktasını
beklemem ve arttığı zaman yeteri kadar
hakkında onu satar yani ya bir süre ve
birlikte hareket edeceksiniz yada
düzenleyerek edeceksin aynı Zamanda
azaldığı zaman insanlar borsa hisseleri
mesela hızlıca ağrısa da ama
yatırımcılar uzun vadeli düşünen
insanlar bu hisseler azaldı zaman onları
topla olur Çünkü panik yapan satılır
olmuş hayatınızda hep kısa vadeli
planlar yaparken bundan 5-10 sene sonra
kendini nerede hayal ediyorum bir ölçüsü
kendim ama bunu gözlemlerken de hep ben
size çok Fix olmayın Çünkü hedefimiz de
çok pis olursanız çok üzülür
hedeflerinizi esnek kur da şu alanda
başarılı olmak için bunun için yapmış
olmam gereken şeyler ne bunun için bu
alanda başarılı olan örneği Ben bir
akademisyenin bana Bununla ilgili
karşılığı önce dağıtıyorlar gel şimdi
yazar beyefendi gelecek oradan
sorabilirsiniz bu alanda başarılı olmak
için bu adam var Bu kadınlar neler
yapmış benim için bunlardan hangileri
bunları gözlemleri ve bunları akabindeki
tamam tamam mı Gençler çok şanslı bir
meselesini Çünkü her Fransızca İngilizce
biliyorsunuz ben yani üçüncü bilim
koyduğumuz ve kendinizi geliştirmek için
konuşacaksınız kendi kararlarınızı
alıyoruz bir çoğunuz çok büyük bir
kırılma yaşayacak bundan bir iki sene
sonra şu anda 12'ler var karşılıyorum
kendi ayaklarınızın üstünde duracağız
yepyeni bir hayata geçireceksiniz belki
Avrupa'da Belki başka bir ülkede
yaşayacaksınız ben kendi adıma Ben daha
önce tuttum ben kendi adıma cesaret
edemedim Çünkü bunu ama bunları yapar
Ama dediğim gibi esnek olmayı ama
önünüzde ne çıkabileceğini altancı de
değerlendirmeyi unutmayın sizlere
söylemek istediğim aklıma gelenler
bunlar arkadaşlar Hepinizi çok seviyorum
ya